Qué factores provocan este nivel de
violencia
buenas noches para toda la audiencia
bueno en primer lugar por supuesto es
tremendamente preocupante esta cifra que
presenta inepadas y también que le ha
hecho seguimiento a la fundación paz y
Reconciliación que está próxima también
a sacar un informe sobre este tema
principalmente pues creemos que detrás
de la violencia contra los líderes
sociales están disputas por la tierra o
por otro tipo de recursos más en este
caso pues un poco lo que ha pasado con
los temas de paz Total que aún no han
avanzado lo suficiente y no han logrado
que haya una una concreción cierta de
los heces al fuego es muy importante
Pues que el gobierno nacional logre
pactar con estos grupos que está
tratando de negociar la paz Pues que
cesen la violencia contra los líderes
sociales y contra los defensores de
Derechos Humanos particularmente en
zonas como norte de Santander Antioquia
cauca nariño que siempre presentan las
cifras más altas de homicidios y
amenazas contra este tipo de Liderazgo
claro precisamente le pregunto por la el
plan de paz total del gobierno Cómo se
entiende que a pesar que los cese al
fuego no hayan triunfado en su totalidad
digamos las cifras no solamente no hayan
disminuido sino también ha aumentado
sí Bueno yo creo que este año tenemos
varios factores el primero de ellos por
supuesto es que en Colombia es un año
electoral este año vamos a elegir
alcaldes gobernadores consejos y
asambleas Y por supuesto cuando hay un
periodo electoral y más con desde
carácter local es posible que aumente la
violencia nosotros veníamos de un
periodo de tensa calma en 2019 y pues
como se ha deteriorado la paz en el país
en los últimos años pues creemos que
esto tiene que ver precisamente con el
aumento de esta violencia por supuesto
dentro de los liderazgos sociales hay
muchos comunitarios pero también hay
otros por ejemplo de personas que están
haciendo campaña el último
Lamentablemente fue el asesinato ayer en
catatumbo de una persona que estaba
pensando en postularse para esas
elecciones de octubre entonces creo que
ese es uno de los factores el otro sin
duda ha sido una falta de coordinación
con los grupos armados y de poder
establecer que los teses al fuego no
solo tengan que ver con las acciones
contra la fuerza pública sino
especialmente que presenten un alivio
humanitario para las personas que están
en las zonas de conflicto
y por otro lado una de las cosas que
denuncian varias organizaciones es la
impunidad en la que quedan muchos de
estos casos o que cuando hay una
sentencia no se individualiza los
culpables Qué consecuencias tiene esta
situación de bloqueo judicial
básicamente yo creo que siempre le hemos
pedido tanto a la fiscalía como a otros
entes judiciales que agilicen las
investigaciones alrededor de estos
asesinatos y de otro tipo de amenazas
contra los líderes sociales porque en
efecto lo que se ha visto muchas veces
es que en la mayoría de casos esto queda
en la impunidad y no se sabe Quiénes son
los agentes perpetradores de este tipo
de violencia a pesar de que se tiene un
mapa bastante completo y hecho por
varias organizaciones de cuáles son los
grupos armados que tienen operaciones en
ciertas zonas del país Yo creo que por
eso es muy importante no solo el papel
de la fiscalía sino que los dos crímenes
se tomen en serio y que no se hable por
ejemplo de celeridad judicial cuando no
hay muchas sentencias que permitan que
permitan finalmente llegar a los
culpables de este tipo de amenazas que
son muy serias Colombia es uno de los
países que por ejemplo tiene más líderes
ambientales amenazados y asesinados en
el mundo y ha sido una problemática que
se ha ido acumulando con los años sin
que nadie le preste suficiente atención